how does it feel to still be in a
position to be making use it that people
want to consume and how you know it's
crazy I was sitting having coffee
yesterday in my neighborhood and a
family went by they was school was just
out public school around and and school
and buy and there was a girl that was
probably eight years old and she was
blushing and she wouldn't look at me and
her mother said she's a huge fan and so
I talked to her for a few minutes and
then I sat down my wife said so how's
that feel
I said well that's crazy I mean
obviously it's played in her household
but it means something to her and of
course you think well that's that's
amazing that's fantastic and we're used
to our fans and our fans are probably
you know 50 to 70 now and now we have
all these the offspring well the
offspring are having offspring and so to
look out at our audience and see the
breadth of age is stunning there's
nothing you can say about it but that is
stunning we came at a time when all the
factors contributed to bringing balance
to the forefront and Canadian audiences
coincidentally really craving to have
something that reflected their own lives
you know I mean it was great to feel
like you know you were a Springsteen fan
and talking about the Jersey Turnpike or
or British fan and all that kind of
Merseybeat stuff it was a lot different
to think about Bobcaygeon or you know
Gregg's Lake Ontario and and I think
that what happened was one of the
reasons that you know all this started
in the clubs and when people come to the
clubs they would look at the stage and
say I know these guys or I know these
girls they I went to school with them I
I know what this what these people are
like when Gord Downey is a great example
because he's maybe bewildering to some
people in the States but he's completely
recognizable to Canadian fans he we get
him so I think that that was that sort
of fostered this intimate relationship
with between fans and band sense of
ownership for priority and and then
that's been that's going on as the bands
have matured that people have matured
passed it on to taking it on their
travels but it's a part of their home in
their call
and that didn't used to happen it didn't
used to happen when were your kids and
we were kids it was all co-opted in
American culture now all of a sudden
kids grow up knowing that there's a
Canadian culture that reflects them that
they can choose or not choose